alright California right now trying to
outline plans that is the governor there
I got the Newson on how he will slowly
reopen churches and places of worship
throughout the Golden State it could be
problematic trace Gallagher is more from
Los Angeles hey trace hey Neal even
though the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals has blocked president Trump's
order saying places of worship in
California must reopen governor Gavin
Gavin Newsom has decided to open them
anyway and is allowing the counties to
kind of open immediately if they so
choose of course places of worship can
stay closed if they want to but if they
do decide to open the governor has laid
out new guidelines and they are
extensive for example religious services
must limit capacity to 25% or 100 people
depending on the size of the building
all employees and volunteers would have
to be trained on how to keep the virus
from spreading and anyone attending or
presiding over a religious service would
need to wear a mask the state has also
recommended eliminating for now all
singing especially by a choir all group
recitations and of course social
distancing would still be required and
experts say different religions would
have to implement different guidelines
for example Catholics would need to
rework things like Communion and
confession and some mosques have talked
about banning the sharing of prayer rugs
we should note that there is no
enforcement mechanism the sheriff's not
going to come to the churches and harass
people and nobody's going to come and
knock on the confessional so it's all
about self policing Neal but we should
note all of this comes as to churches in
Northern California held services
without permission and both services
turned out to be the source of
coronavirus outbreaks Neal very good
point my friend Reese calendar thank you
very very much